so to me the idea of spacing workouts
throughout the day rather than doing
them all in one go makes a lot of
intuitive sense this is more similar to
how you would have trained in the wild
it's what our bodies evolved to do we
wouldn't have just been inert for 23
hours and then had one hour of intensive
activity that just wouldn't make any
sense instead we'd be constantly
tracking animals climbing trees running
through woods etc so we'd be always kind
of active instead of just briefly
extremely active at the same time I find
that the idea of doing shorter workouts
and multiple times throughout the day
fits into my schedule a lot more easily
I often don't have an hour to not only
work out but then the half hour I need
to get there and get back to have a
shower from sweaty etc 20 minutes over
lunch and then of 10 minutes in the
evening makes a lot more sense and the
great thing is about that is if I miss a
workout it's not the end of the world
because I've still got two other
workouts but I couldn't really find any
useful information online as to whether
or not this was a good idea I found
several studies all saying things like
you can still improve your general
fitness surprise-surprise by training
sporadically throughout the day in this
way they're talking more things like
very basic fitness rehabilitation almost
but that's not really what I'm
interested in I'm interested in
hypertrophy in increasing strength
mobility flexibility skills training etc
can you get those kinds of gains from 10
and 20 minute workouts throughout the
day so there are no concrete answers on
the web I decided I'd use my own fitness
knowledge as well as just testing it
myself to see if it works so for the
last month in a bit
I've been training about three or four
times a day for 10 to 20 minutes maybe
even less sometimes and I did a bit of a
deep dive I did lots of research into
different topics surrounding this
subject to see if I could come up some
logical conclusions and I'm gonna
present those to you now so first things
first in terms of my own personal
experience it's been fantastic training
in those shorter periods has meant I've
been far more consistent with my
workouts and at the same time I've seen
actually growth and strength
improvements that I didn't expect to see
and I probably wouldn't have seen if I'd
stuck to my usual training regime of
course any kind of change might trigger
growth because the body adapts to
whatever you're giving it but in many
ways it kind of makes sense if you've
been watching Jeff Nichols videos he's
been talking about training full-body
five times a week
saying how this improves protein
synthesis because it increases presence
is more times throughout the week for
each muscle group talking about how it
improves blood flow to those muscle
areas and talking about how it allows
you to do more repetitions with good
quality because you're having a long
rest in between so you can increase the
volume without seeing a drop off in
terms of your performance and this is
even truer if you're working out
multiple times per day every time I do
press ups I'm increasing protein
synthesis blood flow neural Drive in
those muscles and as such they're
getting a little spike and in these
subsequent hours they're more likely to
grow and build and get stronger of
course you could risk overtraining this
way but the whole point is that these
shorter workouts aren't really long
enough to create that risk in the first
place
at the same time I'm not saying you need
to train the same body part or even the
same skills in the same attributes you
can go for a run for your first
10-minute workout you could do bicep
curls later on in the day and then you
can do a bunch of pull-ups later on in
the evening and there's no reason that
should make you any more likely to
become fatigued than doing those things
all together in one hour
in fact you're less likely to become
fatigued less likely to injure yourself
because in between them you've had a
huge amount of time to rest and recover
it's then up to you if you want to do
full-body or if you want to do each body
part
I've talked on this channel in the past
about how I like to switch different
modalities use different tools use
different Cadence's so I might do
overcoming isometrics I might do
plyometrics I might do yielding
isometrics or I might just do regular
dynamic repetitions I can split these
into separate workouts and then mix them
up throughout the week and that way I'm
stimulating all kinds of different
things in all kinds of different ways
and that kind of flexibility allows it
to really focus on those things without
getting fatigued and without seeing my
performance drop off when I'm doing each
different aspect this kind of training
obviously lends itself really well to
the greasing the groove that I've been
talking about recently greasing the
groove means that you're going to do a
particular exercise regularly
normally one that's technically
demanding and thereby even though you
might not do enough repetitions in order
to trigger hypertrophy or in order to
cause muscle damage or anything like
that what you're doing is you're
lighting up the neural networks the
areas of the brain responsible for those
movements thereby you're creating
long-term potentiation strengthening the
neural connections and what this does it
allows you to move through that movement
more efficiently thereby exerting more
strength and also thereby learning new
skills that you might otherwise have
struggled with a perfect example is
handstands which I've been practicing a
lot lately I've just been doing three
sets of 20-second handstands whenever I
get a moment
this isn't enough to cause fatigue it
isn't causing any overtraining because
it's not enough of a stimulus to cause
that but it is enough of a stimulus to
light up those brain areas to strengthen
those connections and to ensure that I'm
getting slightly better at balancing
slightly better at listen to me the
prior section every single time I do it
and during my own experiments I can
definitely vouch for this because I've
become much better at doing those
handstands much more quickly than using
any other training method that I've used
in the past and yeah if you do the same
thing doing squats with a lighter weight
and you can become more efficient at
moving through the squat which means
that we can use a heavy weight later on
you'll be able to do it far better
what about hypertrophy what about muscle
endurance what about strength gains you
might be worried that 10 minutes or 20
minutes isn't enough to cause enough of
a stimulus to trigger adaptation and
growth but I disagree because pretty
much any kind of training that you need
to do any kind of stimulus you need can
be gained in just 10 to 20 minutes for
instance if you want to gain your
maximum strength on the bench press then
there's no reason that you can't lift
your 80 to 90 percent rep max for 3 to 4
reps then stop you might want to do a
few warm-up sets first maybe some foam
rolling or whatever but that whole thing
with 2 minute rest times in between
which should be about right that whole
thing is only going to take you 10 to 15
minutes really then you can do your
squats and your deadlift later on in the
day and you'll actually have far more
energy and drive to do those things
meaning that you probably want to start
with higher weight and see faster
progress some people might say aren't
you gonna get less of a testosterone
boost and less of an anabolic response
by doing shorter workouts like this and
that's a good question but actually it
doesn't really matter because when you
spike testosterone in your blood and
growth hormone in response to compound
exercises that doesn't lead to greater
strength gains this has been proven in
research
there'll be an article linked in the
description down below probably and I'll
link to all the studies that support
this in that but yeah the research shows
that these spikes in testosterone don't
lead to greater hypertrophy don't lead
to greater recovery or greater strength
gains you get a spike in testosterone
every time you have sex or watch an
action movie or win a game of cards and
you're not gonna get really massively
strong by doing that regularly so it
really doesn't matter whether you're
doing your 3 big lifts all in one
workout or at 3 different points
throughout the day likewise I've been
doing a lot of high volume calisthenics
lately I'll do a video on this soon so
in a quick workout I might do 150 air
squats I might do 150 press ups and
do 70 pull-ups this kind of thing only
takes about 15 minutes the point is that
I'm trying to keep the rest times as low
as possible to improve my recovery
that's what this is all about I'm trying
to getting pumped for size etc and
strengthen the tendons this short
workout once again definitely triggers
hypertrophy and definitely improves
muscle endurance and it's great for
mitochondria etc and it only takes that
short amount of time likewise if you're
interested in endurance performance and
mitochondria in particular then
obviously high-intensity interval
training may be a 2 bar to session with
a heavy kettlebell that's perfect for
triggering a definite response in a very
short amount of time tabata takes 4
minutes and this is also great for
weight loss and the best thing is again
here you're increasing your metabolism
and the afterburn effect so that extends
throughout the day because every time
you're going back to your baseline
you're getting more activity and again
your body is benefiting from not being
inert which can cause all kinds of
health problems if it's hypertrophy
you're interested in body building then
try running the rack with dumbbell curls
take a dumbbell do 12 reps to failure
then drop down the weight do 10 to
failure 8 to failure and a rest time in
between do that three times
that's enough stimulus to grow your
biceps there is no reason you can't be a
bodybuilder and split your routine up
like this do you think I can see being
difficult is steady-state cardio in
other words improving your ability to go
for a run for an hour this is the said
principle specific adaptation to impose
demands if you want to be able to exert
yourself for long periods then you kind
of need to exert yourself for a long
period using interval training with
longer rest times can trigger some of
the same benefits as steady-state cardio
because of inertia basically your heart
rate ramps up to 90 percent which is
more of a twitch they're not enough to
cause hypertrophy but then it also slows
down gradually meaning that if you go
for a walk maybe for two minutes that's
going to mean you're spending some time
with your heart rate at 70 and 60
percent going for long runs improves
other things as well though for instance
it helps to improve your ability to take
in oxygen you can mimic this a little
bit using something like a training mask
which I've talked about on this channel
before but yeah it's not gonna be as
good as going for long runs but if it is
something you'd like to incorporate them
perhaps that could be the exception to
the rule you go for a couple of long
runs and the rest of time you're
splitting your workouts throughout the
day so to conclude there's no good
reason why splitting your workouts
throughout the day would lead to lesser
gains in terms of aesthetics or in terms
of performance and in many cases it
would actually be beneficial
another exam
of something that actually would hugely
benefit from splitting the workouts up
is mobility same goes for things like
balance and for hand-eye coordination
all these things you can train an awful
lot I find this is a particularly good
way to integrate lots of different types
of training lots of different training
modes which I've talked about a lot on
this channel as well as to fit a lot of
training into a really busy and hectic
schedule but you won't want to pop to
the bathroom and splash yourself down
afterwards obvious is much easier for me
because I work from home so I recommend
that you all work from home obviously
failing that there are ways around this
such as to do your workouts in the
morning before work during lunch and in
the evening after work twice maybe you
have a caveat is that it's really
important that you make your training
sessions intense enough in order to get
the response that you're looking for the
shorter the amount of time you're doing
this workout in the more intense it
needs to be you need to do roughly the
same amount that you would do for that
particular trait or that particular
muscle group in order to trigger the
response looking to get the meed the
minimal effective dose this is something
you'll be able to sense with time as you
become more used to training and so
that's one arguments may be trying this
out once you're more accustomed to
training using a more conventional
method so yeah I'm gonna carry on
splitting my workouts into lots of
little bits I me know in the comments
down below if this is something you guys
might do I'd love to hear your thoughts
if you like this kind of alternative
philosophical cross modal approach to
training then you'll love my ebook and
training program super functional
training and you can find a link to that
in description down below you also go to
find a link to my website over there so
check it out and if you enjoyed this
video then please leave a like subscribe
share it around there helps me out
immensely thanks a ton for watching and
I'll see you next time bye for now